hidden in New York City's garment
district on 37th Street between 8th and
9th avenues building 306 lies a
one-of-a-kind freight entrance and
inside you'll find deliveries and
something delicious you weren't
expecting that were you
I told you it was hidden inconspicuous
at first but take a closer look through
these doors and you'll find a small but
mighty latin-american restaurant called
acuario cafe meet the owner - our loaf
of bread we've been here for 26 years
I'm boiling Dominican in I growing in
United States thank you
me and my wife we was busy and since I
bring myself to have been out we started
by factoring the money to cook all the
meat of the rice we cook it like a
hundred pound of the rice not too many
people see in the kitchen maybe one or
two is that easy to make all the food
where we do everything fresh aquario
opens at 10 a.m. and by 11 a.m. a huge
crowd of New Yorkers are lined up
waiting for a hot plate I make people
get hungry when they see my food we have
a recipe from my grandmother and I grew
up eating the same and now I do the same
thing for my customer
the menu is constantly changing but
customers can usually expect poyo
guisado Grabow guisado
and forget it's dominicanos and the most
popular of them all goat meat we got to
make every day because they low-balled
me yeah
but I know what you're thinking why
choose to open a restaurant in such a
small place thanks to work in the
factory and when I got 20 years old here
in same building when I got the
opportunity to buy display but friend
told me install and make it resin being
and say oh my god this is good and I
started from there I started for 350
they play now if I die he sells hundreds
of these plates a day and his success is
all thanks to word-of-mouth everybody
beats somebody people refrain family and
that's why I got all the people I got a
customer be here but if I here with me
we taking their customer like a family
it's easy I see they need it I give it
for free yeah
buta melting I never gonna move from
here they see my baby yeah and you never
get out from your baby
[Music]